en fait ce que ce que propose la loi se
transférer un mélange entre les pouvoirs
de police et les pouvoirs de justice à
facebook et à toutes les plateformes aux
grandes plate forme dont celle là mais
pour moi les grandes plateformes ont
déjà trop de pouvoir et en fait les
propos haineux n'y a pas que sur
facebook qui m'emmerde c'est moi les
propos racistes quand c'est décrit dans
les tribunes du stade des princes ça me
fait chier au moins autant que sur
facebook quand c'est les remarques d'un
policier dans un commissariat
je trouve ça au moins aussi grave que
quand c'est un petit con sur twitter
et curieusement un policier qui tient
des propos racistes dans le commissariat
la police n'a pas 24 heures pour le
sanctionner en fait elle ne fonctionne
jamais où l'arrivée un blog ouais c'est
pas sûr mais ça c'est exactement le même
type de problème sur notre société
affiche le fait qu'elle ne veut plus des
propos racistes des propos sexistes des
propos homophobes et ne le fais pas ça
je sais pas quels sont les moyens de la
plateforme pharos à laquelle on peut
dénoncer des contenus haineux je pense
qu'ils sont faibles
je pense que la loi n'a pas prévu de les
augmenter très dans les dents les
morceaux de loi dont j'avais déjà
discuté avec laeticia avia il ya le fait
par exemple de créer un parc est
spécialisée sur les questions de
numérique
ça c'est un très bon point et je pense
que tout le monde est pour
si ce mot si ce parc est doté des moyens
qui vont bien si les policiers qui mène
ses enquêtes ont les bonnes formations
pour faire les réquisitions dans les
bonnes formes
j'ai vu passer l'info il ya quelques
jours il ya des pays qui ont 80 % de
réponses de twitter la france 40 et des
poussières
pourquoi parce qu'on s'est pas posé les
questions parce qu'en fait les questions
sont mal posé et quand on pose mal la
question de la plateforme répond pas
certes sa part en contentieux sa part en
conflit sur du droit californien qui a
peu de chances d'aboutir
juste parce que nos policiers savent pas
formulé les questions comme il faut
savent pas avoir les bons éléments
techniques etc
sa demande à être formés je peux
comprendre que le policier du
commissariat du coin
il sait pas forcément comment faire ça
il est peut être épaulé par une
direction parisienne mais cap accepter
qu'un pas que ça à faire
voilà avoir ça c'est typiquement un
élément de la loi qui est intéressant à
voir un parc est spécialisée dans le
numérique pour pouvoir saisir beaucoup
plus vite les plateformes
moi je trouve ça très bien
[Musique]